you know we brought to you last night
exclusive news about what was happening
behind the scenes new and shocking
details about the activities of the
Broward County police under the
leadership of sheriff Scott Israel we
shared with you a department email that
was kind of bizarre asking officers may
be ordering officers pleading with
officers to defend the sheriff it read
quote at the moment we find our agency
up against a flurry of media allegations
and a personal attack against our
sheriff sheriff Israel stood with us now
we must stand with him it's important
that they know we stand as one hey guys
this should be not about saving anyone's
backside but about transparency not
protecting the sheriff or anyone else
remember sheriff Israel has endorsed gun
control and for that he won praise from
student activists and this is happening
as his department's actions before
during and after the horrific school
shooting are now being investigated by a
separate state commission when
challenged Israel
don't forget an elected Democrat Sheriff
brags about his amazing leadership but
it may not have been so amazing last
night we reported exclusively that
sources close to the Broward Sheriff's
Office are telling us that deputies on
the scene of the shooting were told not
to enter the school unless their body
cameras were turned on okay well since
they did not have body cameras they
didn't engage the shooter or enter the
school the sheriff's office by the way
has not disputed a report when asked
about the deputies who failed to enter
the school building Broward
superintendent Robert Runcie said quote
there potentially could have been law
enforcement that were sitting on the
sidelines again we'll see what comes out
on the investigation Broward County
Sheriff's Office and the FBI has all the
video related to this we have none of it
in our possession they made that clear
they came
they gave us a warrant and a subpoena
and they took it all
but remember sheriff Israel said that
the videos may never be released another
bizarre comment how do you say that and
it's not clear if the feds have the
video as well it would even be his sole
decision at this point and then there
are the parkland floor to school
students they've been through a lot and
for anyone has been conscious since
valentines day the media has featured
these kids wall-to-wall their passion
their words and I'd argue that their
pain and loss is at times yeah being
exploited by anti-gun activist sometimes
using them as proxies even remember this
from the CNN Town Hall senator Rubio
it's hard to look at you and not look
down the barrel of an ar-15 or not look
at Nicholas Cruz but the point is you're
here can you tell me right now that you
will not accept a single donation from
the NRA
nice well I don't know as some of the
exchanges I imagine the sheriff wouldn't
probably like it if his officers were
spoken to in that tone well he then
revealed himself we do need to have some
gun control reform 18 year old kid
they're not adults yet they're goals
they're in high school these kids should
not have a rifle do you hear what he
said kids they're still in high school
they're going through a lot it's
something called growing up and sheriff
Israel made unwittingly one of the
salient points here why on earth should
teenagers dictate policy on gun control
now the Second Amendment or frankly
anything else for that matter
now without diminishing their pain their
sadness I'm not really smart I think or
their right to express their opinion
about the slaughter of course of their
fellow classmates why should their
political or policy views I mean we're
talking sometimes 14 15 16 year-old kids
be given special consideration well when
they're not insulting congressmen or
senators they're advising them on gun
policy you just met with about five
students from Marjory Stoneman Douglas
High School in parkland Florida you know
I've heard a lot of conservatives say
these kids aren't experts why are they
having an influence on this debate but
you met with them so what did you think
it's high school kids a sympathetic
group obviously been a very very
articulate committed bunch of kids and
they are obviously social media savvy
and that's why I think they're having
the impact that they're having they're
organized and and they're here and so
I'm glad they are I hope they keep it up
these guns are out there on the streets
that people who may be unstable are able
to get it just as anybody else if we
ever want to end this we have to start
at the federal level because that is
where the law is supreme that is where
we have to take action thinking of
Senator flake for a moment who's
retiring because he's at 18% approval I
actually probably would prefer the
students to
most of his advisors who've been
advising him over the years but that
having been said before three of the
students went on Ellen DeGeneres's very
popular talk show a Jif of them
backstage appeared on Twitter that's
kind of cool like they're having fun and
they look kind of like a little Oscar
nominees it looks they looked adorable
perhaps the Wall Street Journal's bill
McGurn he raised I think the best
question may be about kids supposedly
turn policy experts he wrote the
following quick show of hands for those
with children how many of you look to
your teens for political wisdom whether
it's the daughter obsessing over her
snapchat streaks or the son who would
spend his day eating Doritos and binge
gaming Grand Theft Auto if you let him
okay be honest I have three kids did you
raise your hand I didn't think so and
that's the angle